-Performing "Hold the Line"
from his new album,
"The Atlas Underground Fire,"
here is Tom Morello
featuring Grandson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Nobody said
it would be easy ♪
♪ Nobody said
that it would all be fine ♪
♪ But to get where we're going ♪
♪ Brother,
you've gotta hold the line ♪
♪ It ain't a matter of if ♪
♪ Nah, it's just
a matter of time ♪
♪ But to get where we're going ♪
♪ Sister, gotta hold the line ♪
♪ You gotta stay steadfast ♪
♪ Tread lightly ♪
♪ 'Cause they're looking for
a reason to knock you down ♪
♪ But you can't ask ♪
♪ Too politely ♪
♪ In the trenches,
you gotta get loud ♪
♪ Hold the line ♪
♪ Unh ♪
♪ Don't pay 'em no mind ♪
♪ Oh-ho ♪
♪ Hold the line ♪
♪ Nobody said
it happens overnight ♪
♪ But if you're looking
for a sign ♪
♪ Remember everybody
that stood up before you ♪
♪ Oh, they hold the line ♪
♪ They wanna tell you
you're already free ♪
♪ Put these chains on
and rob you blind ♪
♪ When they co-op the movement ♪
♪ Don't trip,
just hold the line ♪
♪ Hold the line ♪
♪ Ahh ♪
♪ Don't pay 'em no mind ♪
♪ Oh-ho ♪
♪ Hold the line ♪
♪ Unh ♪
♪ You gotta stay steadfast ♪
♪ Tread lightly ♪
♪ 'Cause they're looking for
a reason to knock you down ♪
♪ But you can't ask ♪
♪ Too politely ♪
♪ In the trenches,
you gotta get loud ♪
♪ You gotta stay steadfast ♪
♪ Tread lightly ♪
♪ 'Cause they're looking for
a reason to knock you down ♪
♪ But you can't ask ♪
♪ Too politely ♪
♪ In the trenches,
you gotta get loud ♪
♪ Hold the line ♪
♪ Unh ♪
♪ Don't pay 'em no mind ♪
♪ Oh-ho ♪
♪ Hold the line ♪
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]